look what rich people do with their kids
historically
they send them to get a liberal arts
education well do you think it's because
they're stupid that's not why they did
that they know that there isn't anything
that makes you more powerful than being
literate and articulate yeah and sir you
might say well you didn't get trained in
anything specific and maybe you need to
buttress your liberal arts degree with
training in something specific but being
able to communicate especially as you
rise up the ranks in any organization
there isn't anything that serves you
better than your ability to communicate
I mean you read to learn you communicate
to negotiate to plan to strategize to
encourage other people to bring them on
board to put them on your side